This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个I-Heart播客。百分之二。这就是有电梯可乘时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即数字TWO点，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何平台上收听。欢迎收听《回首往事》播客。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的嘉宾包括朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《回首往事》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《学得艰难》节目，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行一些在任何地方都极其不安全但却必须进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执业专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人背负着一副铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着仅仅因为你有这种能力。你就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《学得艰难》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探，才能揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean is.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任意平台上收听《受困的爱》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化与转型，以及它们意味着什么。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of your 20s.
对我们的心理。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能来到这里收听又一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析你二十多岁的心理学。
Anxiety feels like such a curse. I'm just going to come out and say it. I think a lot of us have probably wished for a day where we weren't anxious just one day. What might that be like? Or we've considered, you know, what our lives would look like if we weren't held back by these hypothetical fears about what may or may not happen, what others might think, what disasters await, what terrible things could go wrong in our future. It is a huge burden at times. Even if it comes and goes in waves, me and my anxiety, my power, we go way back. I remember distinctly.
焦虑感觉就像是一种可怕的诅咒。我就直说了吧。我想我们很多人大概都曾期盼过有一天不会感到焦虑，哪怕就一天。那会是一种什么样的体验呢？或者我们曾想过，如果我们没有被这些关于可能会发生或不会发生的事情、别人会怎么想、会有什么灾难等待着我们、未来会出什么可怕差错的假设性恐惧所拖累，我们的生活会是什么样子。有时候，这真是一个巨大的负担。即使它一阵阵地来去，我和我的焦虑、我的力量，我们的渊源可深了。我清晰地记得。
so clearly having my first ever panic attack about the movie, The Never Ending Story when I was eight years old at like a school movie night. And since then I've always had these moments of just extreme panic and anxiety that can go on for months or would just be this baseline of just nervousness for kind of as long as I can remember. I think I said in a recent episode that there have even, you know, been times in my life when I've worried about the fact that I'm not angry. about anything, which is absolutely bizarre. I really begun to realize that my anxiety was almost
清清楚楚地记得我人生中的第一次恐慌发作，那是在我八岁时的一次学校电影之夜，看的电影是《大荒芜的故事》。从那以后，我总是会经历这种极度恐慌和焦虑的时刻，这种状态可以持续几个月，或者就像我记忆中那样，一直保持着一种基准的紧张感。我想我在最近的一集里说过，在我的生活中甚至还出现过这样的时刻：我居然会担心自己为什么什么都不生气。这简直太离谱了。我真的开始意识到，我的焦虑几乎是
comforting in a strange way. It provided me with an illusion of security that felt quite nice when actually, although it was making me feel nice, was making me feel like I could anticipate every single problem that would happen in my life. A, that wasn't the case. Things happened that I never could have thought of and B, it was actually taking away from a lot of my experiences and a lot of the joyful experiences that made up for the anxious ones. You know, I would just sit with my anxious thoughts and try and problem solve them, which I think is something that we've all done. I would try and think my way through a scenario that, you know, is completely irrational. And that is just never going to work because even when on the rare occasion,
以一种奇怪的方式带给我安慰。它给了我一种虚假的安全感，感觉相当不错；但实际上，虽然它让我感觉良好，却让我觉得自己能够预料到我生活中的每一个问题。A，事实并非如此。有些事情发生了，是我怎么也想不到的；B，它实际上剥夺了我的许多体验，以及许多能够弥补焦虑情绪的快乐体验。你知道的，我只会坐在那里任由焦虑的想法折磨自己，并试图去解决它们，我想这也是我们所有人都做过的事。我会试图用自己的思维去推演一个完全不切实际的场景。而这根本是行不通的，因为即使在罕见的情况下，
and I would get through it, my brain would just present me with a bigger and even trickier hypothetical. So it felt quite never-ending. And then a few years back, I started doing things differently. I stopped letting my anxiety kind of be the loudest voice in the room. I stopped letting it, you know, always be in control. And I kind of started finding ways to almost play with my anxious thoughts to like beat them at their own game. combining what I knew scientifically and psychologically about anxiety and how it operates, but also by kind of playing these mind games, these mind tricks, and establishing like some pretty,
我挺过去了，我的大脑也只会抛给我一个更大、更棘手的假设问题。所以感觉就像没完没了了一样。然后，在几年前，我开始尝试不同的做法。我不再让焦虑成为房间里声音最大那个。我不再让它（你知道的）永远占据主导地位。我开始寻找各种方法，几乎像是和焦虑的想法做游戏，以其人之道还治其人之身。将我在科学和心理学上对焦虑及其运作机制的了解结合起来，同时通过玩这些思维游戏、思维把戏，并在不断摸索中建立起一些非常。
really, really useful tricks and tips and strategies through trial and error. And what actually made me feel better did require a little bit of work, but it really helped me change my thinking from anxiety as a burden, to anxiety is something that is a part of me that I can make work for me, that I can leverage in some small way. And that's exactly what I want to talk about today. Four of the ways that I've really been able to make anxiety work for me, even in really, really tough times, terrible times, really panicky, anxious times. These strategies have been like my greatest tools. And recently, I've really had to put them to the test again and slowly but surely they have helped me out of a tough
非常实用的技巧、诀窍和策略。让我感觉好一点的方法确实需要付出一点努力，但它真的帮我改变了思维方式：不再把焦虑视作一种负担，而是把焦虑视作我的一部分，我可以让它为我所用，在某种程度上加以利用。这正是我今天要谈的内容。我真正能够让焦虑为我所用（即使在非常艰难、糟糕、极度恐慌和焦虑的时刻）的四种方法。这些策略就像是我最伟大的工具。最近，我真的再次把它们付诸实践，它们慢慢地、稳步地帮我度过了难关。
situation so i wanted to share it with you i hope that you can learn something all of these tips are really practical and accessible you could literally try them all today if you wanted so i really hope it at least changes how you think about your anxious thoughts even if it doesn't change your life without further ado let's get into the four ways that we can make anxiety work for us Having a refresher on what anxiety actually is might sound really simple to begin with, but sometimes when we're really wrapped up in our fear and our panic and our worry, we think that our anxiety means more than it does. And we really need to be, firstly, grounded in the fact, grounded in the facts of what we're going through.
所以我很想分享给你们，希望你们能有所收获。所有这些技巧都非常实用且容易上手，如果你愿意，你今天就可以把它们全部试一遍。所以我真心希望它至少能改变你对焦虑想法的看法，即使它未能改变你的生活。废话不多说，让我们切入能够让焦虑为我们所用的四种方法。重新复习一下焦虑到底是什么，听起来可能非常简单，但有时当我们深陷恐惧、恐慌和担忧之中时，我们会觉得焦虑的含义比它实际上的要严重得多。我们首先需要做的是，立足于现实，立足于我们正在经历的事实。
You may think you know all the information about anxiety. There is a lot to know, and you probably do know quite a bit. but when you're operating from a place of survival and pure fear, your ability to actually remember this valuable information becomes quite clouded. You know, you're just not thinking straight. And we think in those moments that our anxiety is much more valid than it is, that we should believe every single thought that passes through our brains, that every opinion made up situation could be true.
你可能觉得你掌握了关于焦虑的所有信息。需要了解的信息确实很多，而且你可能也确实了解不少。但当你出于生存本能和纯粹的恐惧来行事时，你实际记住这些宝贵信息的能力就会变得相当模糊。你知道的，你根本无法冷静思考。我们在那种时刻会觉得，我们的焦虑比实际情况更加真实，我们应该相信脑海中闪过的每一个想法，每一个观点和虚构出来的场景都可能是真的。
Because we've been hardwired to prioritize thoughts that relates. to our survival, that relate to fear, that have an emotional tone to them, even if they're actually not that useful. We, I think, essentially, trust that our mind and our body, and to a certainly extent, must be doing what it thinks is best. It must know what's best. It must be making us pay attention to these hypotheticals because we are in real danger. But what we need to realize is that our trust is misplaced because anxiety's job, and this might shock you, maybe it won't, but anxiety's job is to be irrational. That is literally its job. It is to present us with the worst case scenarios to catastrophes, to stress, to project, not to be truthful. That is not
因为我们的大脑生来就被赋予了优先处理与生存相关的、与恐惧相关的、带有情感色彩的想法的倾向，哪怕这些想法其实并没有那么有用。我想，本质上我们是在相信，我们的大脑和身体在某种程度上一定是在做它认为最好的事情。它一定知道什么才是最好的。它一定是在逼迫我们关注这些假设，因为我们正身处真正的危险之中。但我们需要意识到的是，我们的信任放错了地方，因为焦虑的工作——这可能会让你感到震惊，也许不会——焦虑的工作就是不切实际。这简直就是它的本职工作。它向我们呈现最坏的情况、灾难、压力和预测，而不是说实话。那可不在。
part of its job description. It's not to see a situation realistically. And why exactly is that the case? Well, because anxiety is your body and your brain trying to protect you against a perceived threat or a stressful situation, often by exaggerating an outcome or exaggerating the reality of the situation to, you know, either A, help motivate you or B, try and get you to problem solve before the situation occurs. You know, I often think about anxiety like your mind trying to give you a practice exam, but all the questions and scenarios are questions and scenarios that you'd never actually encounter in the real world or in the real exam. And they're often impossible to answer. They'll never show up in real life. And all the while, you're convincing yourself or your anxiety is
它的工作职责范围内。它不是要现实地看待一种情况。为什么会这样呢？很简单，因为焦虑是你身体和大脑试图保护你免受感知到的威胁或压力情境的伤害，通常是通过夸大结果或夸大局势的现实，来达到以下目的：A，帮助激励你；B，试图让你在情况发生之前就去解决问题。你知道的，我经常把焦虑比作你的大脑试图给你进行的一场模拟考试，但里面所有的考题和情景都是你在现实世界或真正的考试中永远不会遇到的考题和情景。而且它们往往是无法回答的。它们永远不会在现实生活中出现。与此同时，你却在说服自己，或者你的焦虑在。
convincing you, you know, this isn't a practice exam. This is the real deal. You have to take this seriously. This could actually be happening right now. You know, take feeling anxious about the future. What you're really experiencing is a fear of uncertainty because there is a lot you don't know. You might not know how your career is going to turn out. You might not know whether that big risk will pay off, whether you're going to meet your people, whether you're going to find love. So there is a lot of empty space. There are a lot of unknowns.
说服你，这不是一场模拟考试。这是来真的。你必须认真对待。这可能现在正在发生。你知道的，对未来感到焦虑。你真正经历的是对不确定性的恐惧，因为有很多事情是你不知道的。你可能不知道你的职业生涯会如何发展，你可能不知道那个巨大的风险是否会有回报，你是否会遇到志同道合的人，你是否会找到真爱。所以这里有很大的空白。有太多的未知。
Our anxiety likes to fill that space with the worst case scenario to basically say, okay well if you can handle this if you have a plan then we'll be fine if it comes true here's the thing though those scenarios rarely if not ever come true the scenario in which you lose everything and a fire and you make a huge mistake at work and you never get a job again and all your loved ones die that isn't going to come true the fear of you know suddenly being diagnosed with the rare disease when you were otherwise healthy, that isn't going to come true. Or, you know, your thought that everyone secretly dislikes you. You've somehow said something to upset all your close friends without anyone mentioning it.
我们的焦虑喜欢用最坏的情况来填补这个空白，基本上就是在说：“好吧，如果你能应付这个，如果你有一个计划，那么如果它成真了，我们会没事的。”但问题是：这些场景很少、甚至几乎从不会成真。你在火灾中失去一切、在工作中犯了大错、再也找不到工作、所有挚爱都离世的场景，是不会成真的。那种在你原本健康的突然被诊断出患有罕见疾病的恐惧，是不会成真的。或者，你知道的，你认为每个人都暗中讨厌你的想法。你不知怎么说了些话惹恼了所有的好朋友，却没有一个人提起。
That is false. It's not going to come true. It is your brain serving you up scenarios to give you a really vigorous, mental and physical workout. So if they were to happen, you would be okay because you've already experienced the anxiety towards this situation beforehand. Hopefully that makes a lot of sense to you. I think when we begin to acknowledge that this is our brain trying to protect us,
这是假的。它不会成真。这是你的大脑在向你抛出各种场景，给你进行一次非常剧烈的心智和身体锻炼。所以如果这些事情真的发生了，你也会安然无恙，因为你之前已经体验过对这种情况的焦虑了。希望这很好理解。我想，当我们开始承认这是大脑在试图保护我们，
but just not doing a very great job or being very helpful at all, we see our situation a bit more clearly. And it has always, always helped me to remind myself that my opinion about a situation is just an opinion. Nothing more, nothing less. There's often very little evidence for what I'm, thinking and as much as I try you know I can't tell the future I'm not I don't have that rare magical ability I cannot anticipate how this will work out so I just have to be accepting of what comes
只是做得不是很好、或者一点也没有帮助时，我们就能更清楚地看到自己的处境。对我而言，一直以来最管用的一招就是提醒自己：我对某种情况的看法仅仅是一种观点。不多不少，仅此而已。我所思考的事情往往缺乏证据，而且无论我多么努力，你知道的，我都无法预知未来。我没有那种罕见的魔法能力，我无法预料事情会如何发展，所以我只能选择接受接下来发生的事情。
of course you know that's very easy to think but when your anxiety is accompanied by a number of physical symptoms like shaking like a rapid heartbeat shortness of breath trembling nausea sweating or that feeling of disassociation or being unreal it can become even more unpleasant. And I will say it makes it feel a lot more immediate. As much as those thoughts may not be true, what you're going through certainly is. The physical feeling you're going through is very real.
当然，你知道的，道理很简单，但当你的焦虑伴随着一系列身体症状时，比如发抖、心跳加快、呼吸急促、颤抖、恶心、出汗，或者那种解离感或不真实感，这种体验就会变得更加令人不快。我得说，这会让人感觉更加迫在眉睫。尽管那些想法可能不是真的，但你正在经历的绝对是真的。你正在经历的身体感受是非常真实的。
Whether that is displayed through panic attacks, through like consistent underlying anxiety or just intrusive, repetitive thoughts, it is definitely not a comfortable experience. I don't think anyone is like, oh yeah, I love feeling anxious. That's one of my favorites. And I'm not going to be like some guru who's going to sell you snake oil and say that I can make that go away immediately or that I can cure you. But what I do want to talk about is four ways that we can take that feeling and not just completely eliminate it, but make it work for us.
无论这种体验是通过恐慌发作、持续的潜在焦虑，还是通过侵入性的重复想法表现出来，这绝对不是一种舒适的体验。我想没有人会觉得：“哦，是的，我喜欢焦虑的感觉。这是我的最爱之一。”我不会像某些兜售灵丹妙药的世外高人那样，宣称我能让这种感觉立刻消失或者我能治愈你。但我想聊的是四种方法，我们可以利用这种感觉，不只是彻底消除它，而是让它为我们所用。
And make do leverage the anxious hand, the anxious mind that you've been dealt. you know, like I said before, it's been at least 16 years that I've kind of been in the business of anxiety, but only in the last like two to three that I've really started approaching this tension, these feelings, these thoughts in a way that initially felt so counterintuitive, but actually which really, really worked. And that's the thing that I've learned with anxiety that I've found. You kind of have to beat it at its own game and just be as a irrational and delusional in your belief that you'll be fine as your anxiety is irrational and delusional in its belief that the world is falling apart. You need to be just as persistent as your
并善加利用你所拿到手的焦虑之手、焦虑之脑。你知道的，就像我之前说的，我在“焦虑界”摸爬滚打至少有16年了，但直到最近两到三年，我才真正开始以一种最初感觉极其反直觉、但实际上却非常非常奏效的方式来处理这种紧张感、这些感受和这些想法。这就是我在焦虑中学到的、也是我发现的方法。你必须以其人之道还治其人之身，在坚信自己会没事的信念上，要像你的焦虑坚信世界正在崩溃那样不切实际和异想天开。你必须和你的。
anxiety is and just as imaginative. But the thing is that you already know that you can be all those things because your anxiety is displaying that you have that capability. So you can use, you know, the methods that your anxiety is using to scare you to kind of scare it back. This really brings me to the first way that I stopped fighting my anxiety and really made it work for me. And that is really tricking myself into believing that anytime I feel anxiety, it's actually just excitement. And choosing to label the sensations differently to how my mind wants to label them. If my anxious mind wants to make things up, wants to label things differently as a threat when they're not, If my anxious mind wants to lie to me, well, I can lie right back.
焦虑一样执着，一样充满想象力。但问题是，你其实已经知道自己可以具备所有这些特质，因为你的焦虑正展现出你拥有这种能力。所以你可以利用焦虑用来吓唬你的那些方法来反过来吓唬它。这真正引出了我停止与焦虑对抗、让它为我所用的第一种方法。那就是真正地欺骗自己，让自己相信：每当我感到焦虑时，其实那只是兴奋。并选择用一种与我内心原本想贴的标签不同的方式来给这些感觉贴标签。如果我焦虑的大脑想要胡思乱想，想要把事情错误地贴上威胁的标签（而实际上并非如此），如果我焦虑的大脑想要对我说谎，那么，我也可以回敬它一个谎言。
You know, it sounds like I'm fighting this like, you know, mortal enemy. But here's the thing, right? Like, there's a perk, not so much a perk, but something unusual about feeling anxious that works in our favour, anxiety and excitement are actually incredibly similar on so many dimensions. And they tend to actually activate the same kind of arousal pathways in our body. There's a really amazing article from the Harvard Business School titled Get Excited, Reapraising Anxiety as Excitment. And it talks about how both anxiety and excitement are based on knowing, or not knowing what to expect.
听起来我好像在和这个不共戴天的死敌战斗。但事实是，对吧？焦虑有一种好处——与其说是好处，不如说是某种不寻常之处——它对我们有利：焦虑和兴奋在许多维度上其实惊人地相似。它们往往会激活我们体内同一种唤醒通路。哈佛商学院有一篇非常精彩的文章，题为《兴奋起来：将焦虑重新评估为兴奋》。文章谈到了焦虑和兴奋都是基于对预期或不预期的了解。
They're based on high levels of arousal, so basically meaning a similar level of bodily response to a stimulus. And they're based on a sense or a loss of control. when you're excited, you're going to feel perhaps equally jittery, kind of nervous, you're going to feel your heart rate go up, maybe all these thoughts start swirling around about what is possible. That's very similar to an anxious state. The only difference is what we would call positive or negative valence. So valence or valency is this idea in psychology that describes how different emotions have a different emotional effect. even if they feel the same on a physical level.
它们基于高水平的唤醒，基本上意味着对刺激做出相似水平的身体反应。它们基于一种掌控感或失控感。当你兴奋时，你可能会感到同样的心神不宁、有点紧张，你会感觉到心率加快，也许各种关于可能性的想法开始在脑海中盘旋。这与焦虑的状态非常相似。唯一的区别就是我们所谓的正效价或负效价。所以效价或化合价是心理学中的一个概念，它描述了不同的情感如何具有不同的情感效应。即使它们在身体层面的感觉完全相同。
So anxiety and excitement, they feel the same on a physical level, but anxiety has a negative valence, whereas excitement has a positive valence, meaning that the emotional effect of excitement is appealing, it's desirable, it makes us more attracted to a situation, whereas anxiety has that negative valence, it makes us scared, fearful, uncomfortable. So I want you to tap into that positive, emotional,
所以焦虑和兴奋在身体层面的感觉是一样的，但焦虑具有负效价，而兴奋具有正效价，这意味着兴奋的情感效应是吸引人的、令人向往的，它让我们对某种情况更感兴趣，而焦虑具有负效价，它让我们感到害怕、恐惧、不舒服。所以我希望你们去调动那种积极的情感。
valency. If the only thing that is different is how we interpret a feeling, then tell yourself, actually, I'm excited by this feeling. This is an anxiety. This is excitement about how this is going to turn out. I'm excited to see how I manage this. I'm excited to be able to have this human experience. And, you know, I used this technique a lot when I was getting over my fear of flying. I would get incredibly panicked, especially during taking. off and so I would just keep repeating that, you know, this is actually an excited feeling. I'm excited by this feeling. This is not anxiety. These are butterflies. This is not adrenaline. It's enthusiasm. And that same research paper from Harvard that I referenced before actually
效价。如果唯一的不同在于我们如何解读一种感觉，那就告诉自己：其实，我对这种感觉感到兴奋。这不是焦虑。这是对事情结果会怎样的兴奋。我很高兴看到自己如何应对这一切。我很高兴能有这样的人生体验。你知道的，当我克服恐飞症时，我经常使用这个技巧。我以前会变得极其恐慌，尤其是在起飞时。所以我会不断地对自己重复：这其实是一种兴奋的感觉。我对这种感觉感到兴奋。这不是焦虑。这是内心的小鹿乱撞。这不是肾上腺素。这是热情。我前面提到的哈佛那篇研究论文其实。
concluded that using this technique can improve our performance like a lot in certain situations, especially when it comes to things to do with social anxiety, public speaking, specific phobia situations and it's a much better strategy if you know than trying to just completely shut down our anxiety completely because going from anxious to calm is a lot harder there are a lot more nuances and differences compared from compared to going from anxious to excited because they are on the same kind of end of the spectrum that is tip number one but we're going to take a short break I hope that you stay with us and I hope that you are excited for the next three strategies I have for you when we're back.
得出的结论是：在某些情况下，使用这种技巧可以大大提升我们的表现，特别是在处理社交焦虑、公开演讲、特定恐惧症等情况时。而且，这比试图完全彻底地关闭我们的焦虑要好得多，因为从焦虑转变为平静要难得多，其中涉及的细微差别和差异要比从焦虑转变为兴奋多得多，因为它们处于同一种光谱的同一端。这是第一条小贴士，但我们要稍作休息。希望你们能继续收听，也希望你们对接下来要分享的另外三种策略感到兴奋，我们休息后见。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too much. complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were
2%。这就是有电梯可乘时依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析坚韧精神、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾坚信种子油是。
inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
天生具有炎症性的。我们搞错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后蜕变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。即T-W-O-Persent，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小肯姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时？我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me. not just because of crack.
乔治·布什和小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回首往事》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。其中包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，他大谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。明确一下，84年对我的意义重大。不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我随时准备在节目里聊可卡因，不过只是让大家知道。我是说，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这里面有一条主线了。我们现在甚至还把艾滋病也摆到台面上来了。谢谢你把这句话说完。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you Get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, learn the hard way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist,
是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《回首往事》。欢迎收听我的新播客《学得艰难》，我是主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师。
Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking.
科尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的个人经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我在说的是。
Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough,
特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某事时，会过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变得只剩下赢与输。史蒂夫·بBurns（史蒂夫·伯恩斯）、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得作为地球上的一员，做一个好人很重要？还是你做个好人只是因为你害怕？因为那是两种截然不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我和科尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《学得艰难》中，进行关于疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《学得艰难》并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场寻父丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会揭露了她证词中明显的自相矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们将揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我简直惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于自食恶果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice. is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. The easiest way to tell if something is an anxious thought is when it starts with what if. What if the world collapses?
女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《受困的爱》播客。要判断某件事是否属于焦虑的想法，最简单的方法就是看它是不是以“万一”开头。万一世界崩塌了怎么办？
What if my worst fear comes true? What if I never achieve what I want? What if I lose it all? A true fear, something that is actually dangerous in the moment, wouldn't require that. that what if prefix because you would know it was happening. It would be happening right now in the moment. And this is really valuable to pay attention to because the moment you find yourself spiraling, overthinking, getting repetitive with your thoughts, and they all start with what if, that is anxiety, that is not reality, it's a thought, not a fact. Here's how you can make this work for you. Again,
万一我最害怕的恐惧成真了怎么办？万一我永远无法实现我想要的目标怎么办？万一我失去了一切怎么办？真正的恐惧，那种当下真正构成危险的事情，是不需要“万一”这个前缀的，因为你会知道它正在发生。它此时此刻就在发生。这一点非常值得关注，因为当你发现自己陷入恶性循环、过度思考、想法不断重复，并且它们都以“万一”开头时，那就是焦虑，而不是现实。这是一个想法，而不是事实。你可以这样让它为你所用。再次强调，
what you're really fearing here is the unknown. And it's not uncommon for us to have. have, you know, five, six, seven different hypotheticals about what could happen, all going at once, all swirling around, or feeling equally scary and unlikely, what we forget to realize is that they can't all possibly come true. But yet we feel bombarded with an almost cumulative worry, right? That each of these hypotheticals could be a possibility. And that's one of the first ways that we see that anxiety is really, really irrational, because that's not possible. and I want you to fight these unknowns with knowns. Yes, you don't know how the future will pan out or what will happen in this situation,
这里你真正恐惧的是未知。我们脑海中同时出现五、六、七种关于可能发生事情的假设，所有这些假设同时翻滚、交织，都显得同样可怕且不太可能，这其实并不少见，而我们往往忘记了一点：它们不可能全都成真。然而，我们却感到自己被一种近乎累积的担忧所轰炸，对吧？仿佛每一个假设都有可能发生。这就是我们看到焦虑其实非常不理智的最初方式之一，因为这根本是不可能的。我希望你用已知来对抗这些未知。是的，你不知道未来会如何发展，也不知道在这种情况下会发生什么，
but you do know a lot of things and you are certain of a lot of things. You know that you are capable. You know that you've survived every situation you've been in before. You know that this is just anxiety. What else do you know? You do know that your fears rarely ever come true. You do know that you are not alone. you do know that you you know many others have been through this and come out the other side there is
但你确实知道很多事情，而且你对很多事情是确信的。你知道自己是有能力。你知道你挺过了你以前经历过的每一次危机。你知道这只是焦虑。你还知道什么？你确实知道你的恐惧很少成真。你确实知道你并不孤单。你确实知道你（你知道的）许多其他人也经历过这一切并挺了过来。这里有
one uncertainty the uncertainty is what's going to happen in this situation what's going to happen next but there are many many certainties and that is what i want you to focus on what you do know what you are certain of compared to what you are uncertain of and see how like the certainties end up stacking up in your favour here's a really great visualization exercise that i use with this as well is i like pretend that I am holding these certainties in my hand and they are these big golden orbs these big like weird golden balls and I like mentally throw them at my fears at my anxious thoughts and I think about the fears as like this big shadowy you know shadowy figure and I'm throwing these big certainty golden orbs at them and they're just crashing through this shadow
一个不确定性，不确定性是这种情况下会发生什么、接下来会发生什么，但有许许多多的确定性，这就是我希望你关注的重点：与不确定性相比，你所知道的、你所确定的事情是什么，然后看看这些确定性最终是如何对你有利的。我还有一个很棒的可视化练习，我也经常将其与此结合使用。我喜欢假装把这些确定性握在手中，它们就像是一个个巨大的金色光球、一个个奇怪的金色球体，我把它们在脑海中向我的恐惧、向我焦虑的想法扔去。我把这些恐惧想象成一个巨大的、阴暗的身影，然后我把这些巨大的确定性金色光球扔向它们，光球直接击碎了这个暗影，
making it smaller and smaller and smaller, making it fall apart until it's gone. And these certainties really pierced through that uncertainty, both in like the visualization but also in your life. Like you really start to believe that, yes, I, you know, you do know that this is going to pass. You do know that there are all these factual things that you can rely on. You do know at the very least that you trust yourself to get through this. That is something that you are absolutely sure of.
让它变得越来越小、越来越小，直到分崩离析，直到彻底消失。这些确定性真正穿透了那种不确定性，无论是在可视化练习中还是在你的生活中都是如此。你会真正开始相信，是的，你知道的（你知道的）这一切终将过去。你确实知道有所有这些你可以依赖的事实。你至少知道你可以信任自己能够度过难关。这是你绝对确凿的事情。
The reason that I find this so effective is because it gives me the opportunity to remember that I am capable no matter what situation I encounter. Again, anxiety's job is to be irrational, but so often afterwards, we never get the opportunity to remember what it was we were fearing because it doesn't come true. So anxiety's job is really to torment us, not to give us factual scenarios that we actually are going to encounter. you can instead use this situation to learn about yourself, to reinforce that you are confident, that you trust yourself rather than trusting your anxiety. And you've got to remember a lot of people don't get tested this way. A lot of people go through life, just assuming things,
我发现这一招如此奏效的原因在于，它让我有机会去记住：无论遇到什么情况，我都有能力应对。再次重申，焦虑的工作就是不切实际，但在事后，我们往往再也没有机会去回想我们曾经恐惧的是什么，因为它并没有成真。所以焦虑的工作实际上是来折磨我们的，而不是给我们提供我们在现实中真的会遇到的真实场景。你可以反其道而行之，利用这种情况来了解自己，来强化自己的自信，让自己学会相信自己而不是相信焦虑。你要记住，很多人并没有经历过这种考验。很多人浑浑噩噩地度过一生，只会做各种假设，
and you're someone who is going to instead take that discomfort, take all those situations in which you felt fear and really pay attention to the fact that you got through it. And really remember that for the future, that you are an incredibly strong person to be facing a battle that is originating from you, that is originating from the deepest fears that you could possibly encounter being made to feel real.
而你却选择了承受那种不适，面对所有那些让你感到恐惧的情景，并真正注意到这样一个事实：你挺过来了。并把这一点牢牢记在未来的人生中——你是一个极其坚强的人，敢于直面一场源于你内心深处的战役，源于你可能遇到的最深恐惧却被逼得感到逼真的战役。
I just think you will experience true pride and joy that you persevered, and I want you to have that experience. I want you to make that happen for yourself. Now, the third way that I make anxiety work for me rather than against me is by personifying my anxiety as something that isn't threatening. So my mom was actually the one who really inspired me to kind of start thinking about my anxiety this way because of something that she said to me once when I was really, really stuck. You know, she'd seen me kind of battle with some pretty existential fears for a long time. And one day she was like, the fears you have now are no different to, when you were a kid and you were scared of the boogeyman,
我只是觉得，你会为自己的坚持不懈感到由衷的自豪和喜悦，我希望你能拥有这种体验。我希望你能为自己实现这一点。现在，我让焦虑为我所用（而不是与我作对）的第三种方法是：将我的焦虑拟人化为一个并不具威胁性的东西。其实是我的妈妈启发了我，让我开始用这种方式来看待我的焦虑，因为她有一次在我陷入极度困境时对我说过的一番话。你知道的，她曾看着我和一些相当形而上的恐惧搏斗了很长一段时间。有一天她说：“你现在的恐惧，和你小时候害怕怪物、
or you were scared of the monster in your closet. You know, it's just all smoke, right? And thinking about my anxiety is this tangible thing that wasn't scary, except for in my imagination, turned a lot of it around for me. So now I try to personify my anxiety as, this is so strange, but as boo from Monsters Inc.
害怕衣橱里的怪兽没有什么不同。”你知道的，这其实都只是一团虚烟，对吧？把我的焦虑想象成这样一个除了在我的想象中之外其实并不可怕的有形事物，彻底改变了我的许多看法。所以现在我试着把我的焦虑拟人化为——这听起来太奇怪了——《怪兽电力公司》里的阿布。
Now, if you've ever seen that movie, it's a classic, I'm assuming that you have, but, you know, Boo is the little girl. and when she's, she's like wearing this little monster costume and she jumps out and she goes like, boo. And obviously like, Sully and Mike Wazowski like get really, really scared, but it's like, it's just a little kid, right? And that's how I like to imagine my anxiety trying to scare me, like a little kid that's like playing and I'm like playing along with them.
如果你看过那部电影，它绝对是一部经典之作，我假设你肯定看过。你知道的，阿布就是那个小女孩。当她穿着那个小怪兽服装跳出来说“布——”的时候。很显然，苏利和迈克·华斯基都会被吓得魂飞魄散，但实际上，这不过是个小孩子，对吧？这就是我喜欢想象我的焦虑试图吓唬我的方式——就像一个小孩子在玩耍，而我也在陪着他们玩。
And they're like, boo. And I'm like, oh, I'm so terrified. How scary. But really I can see that it's just this little harmless being, this little thing that is, you know, not. actually going to hurt me. Because, you know, really, your anxiety is just like a little kid playing make-believe. It can't jump out and rip off your limbs. It can't pull your hair. It can't do anything to you externally. It is a feeling and one that has originated from you. So it will not harm you as uncomfortable as it feels. Giving it a name, giving it a little costume, giving it an identity
他们喊着“布——”，而我则配合着说：“噢，我好害怕呀，太吓人了。”但实际上我能看出这只是一只无害的小可爱，是一个（你知道的）根本不会真正伤害我的小东西。因为，说实话，你的焦虑就像是一个在玩假扮游戏的小孩子。它没法跳出来扯断你的四肢。它没法拽你的头发。它对你的外部世界做不了任何实质性的伤害。它只是一种感觉，而且这种感觉源于你。所以它不会伤害你，尽管这种感觉很不舒服。给它起个名字，给它穿上一件小衣服，赋予它一个身份。
maybe. It lets us remember that what we're really dealing with here is a boogeyman. or in my case, you know, a little kid playing dress up who's trying to scare you. This has the additional benefit of meaning that you can kind of almost speak to your anxiety like it's a person, like it's, you know, an annoying visitor in your house or a little kid, you're asking it to leave, you're in control, and you can kind of also tease it and joke around with it and tell it to chill out. One of my friends calls her anxiety Brian, like brain, but with the eye, and the A swap to get the picture and she's so cute because she'll be like, oh, you know, Brian is just holding us up today so I'm running a little bit late or, you know, Brian is really overthinking this. Can you tell him to chill out? Can you reassure me? Now, you know, it's like if she needs to cancel plans, she needs more information, she needs reassurance, it's not her asking for it, it's Brian. Maybe in a way that kind of reduces some of the stigma or the sense that you're demanding or that you're the all the, problem because this separation of you and your anxiety into a character makes you realize that
也许吧。这能让我们记住，我们在这里真正对付的其实是一个虚构的妖怪。或者在我的例子里（你知道的），是一个玩着化妆游戏、试图吓唬你的小孩子。这样做还有一个额外的好处：你可以几乎像跟一个人对话那样跟你的焦虑对话，就像它是你家里一个烦人的访客或一个小孩子一样，你要求它离开，你才是掌控一切的那个人，你甚至还可以取笑它、跟它开玩笑，告诉它冷静点。我的一个朋友把她的焦虑叫作“布莱恩”（Brian，谐音Brain大脑，但把中间的字母换成了i和a来形成画面），她超级可爱，因为她会说：“噢，你知道的，布莱恩今天把我们耽误了，所以我稍微迟到了一会儿”或者“噢，你知道的，布莱恩对这件事想得太多了。你能让他冷静点吗？你能安慰安慰我吗？”你看，这就好像如果她需要取消计划、需要更多信息、需要安慰时，并不是她在要求这些，而是布莱恩在要求。也许在某种程度上，这减轻了一些污名化，也减轻了那种“你很苛求”或者“你就是所有问题的根源”的感觉，因为把你自己和你的焦虑剥离开来变成一个角色，会让你意识到。
you are in fact not your anxiety you are just a person doing the best they can with what they have and the hand that they've been dealt even if that hand involves a little friend who likes to jump out and scare you my final tip today for making your anxiety work for you rather than against you for reprogramming our relationship with this state is to take the tension, take the hopelessness, take the nervousness and channel it into something creative. That energy you have has to go somewhere. And yes, it can definitely be expressed through tears or panic or muscle tension or trembling, but it can also be expressed emotionally through creation.
事实上，你并不是你的焦虑，你只是一个尽自己最大努力去利用现有条件和手中烂牌的普通人，哪怕手中拿到的烂牌里包含了一个喜欢跳出来吓唬你的小可爱。今天关于如何让焦虑为你所用而非与你作对、如何重塑我们与这种状态之间关系的最后一个小贴士是：接纳这种紧张感、绝望感和焦虑感，并将这些情绪引导转化为某种具有创造力的东西。你拥有的能量必须有个宣泄的出口。是的，它绝对可以通过眼泪、恐慌、肌肉紧张或颤抖来表达，但它同样可以通过创造来进行情感上的表达。
Now, I'm not saying production. I'm not saying to take all that nervous energy and that false alarm focus and be productive and work on, you know, your school project or whatever it is or work on your assignment or doing something that's, you know, necessarily helpful. I'm saying be creative for a reason because what I think really helps us pro-sex anxiety is building something, molding something for the sake of just making something beautiful. anxiety puts us in a state of helplessness, scarcity, stuckness, deficit. We feel like life is kind of meaningless at times or like everything could be taken away from us.
听着，我不是在说要搞生产。我不是指把那些紧张的精力和虚惊一场的专注力转化为什么生产力，去搞什么学校的项目之类的，或者去完成什么作业，或者去做那些所谓必然有帮助的事情。我的意思是，我们要出于某种原因去发挥创造力，因为我认为真正能帮我们缓解焦虑的是去创造某些东西，去塑造某些东西，纯粹为了做出美丽的东西。焦虑把我们置于一种无助、匮乏、卡壳、亏损的状态。有时候我们会觉得生活毫无意义，或者觉得一切都可能被我们夺走。
Our safety, our lives are at risk. Creativity is the exact opposite. Painting, buying $4 clay from your craft store, knitting, building Legos, scrapbooking, diary entries, writing poetry, whatever it is. That shows abundance. That shows healing. That shows that you can be in control. You can put beautiful things back into the world and channel again. Yes, that anxiety. Channel it into something meaningful rather than something meaningless. I cite this paper all the time. So for my regular listeners, I am going to sound like a broken record. But a 2021 paper on the positive effects of creativity looked at over 500. adults who were asked to just engage in a small creative task each day for less than 10 minutes. And after two weeks, their subjective well-being was measured. And what they found was that for those who were given the direction to be creative, they were
我们的安全和生命都处于危险之中。而创造力恰恰相反。画画、花4美元在手工艺品店买黏土、织毛衣、搭乐高、做剪贴簿、写日记、写诗，无论是什么。这展现了丰盛。这展现了疗愈。这表明你可以掌控一切。你可以把美好的事物重新带回这个世界，并再次进行引导。没错，就是那种焦虑。把它引导到有意义的事情上，而不是无意义的事情上。我一直在引用这篇论文。所以对于我的老听众来说，我听起来可能像个碎碎念的复读机。但2021年有一篇关于创造力积极影响的论文，研究了500多名成年人，他们被要求每天花不到10分钟参与一个小小的创造性任务。两周后，研究人员测量了他们的主观幸福感。他们发现，那些被引导发挥创造力的人
so much happier. And the biggest area where the researchers saw a shift was reduced anxiety. in my mind anxiety is just energy and energy doesn't disappear it needs a place to go it needs direction when you begin to master your anxiety more you can kind of channel it in the ways that you want and creative expression is one of the easiest ways to do that initially you take that energy that is all yours it is yours to use and you use it to create to expand to build rather than to let your anxiety convince you that nothing changes, all your fears come true. They won't.
快乐得多。研究人员发现变化最大的领域是焦虑感的减轻。在我看来，焦虑只是一种能量，而能量是不会消失的，它需要一个去处，需要一个方向。当你开始更好地掌控焦虑时，你可以按照自己想要的方式去引导它，而创造性表达最初正是做到这一点的最简单方法之一。你把那些完完全属于你的能量——那是你专属的能量——拿来创造、扩展、构建，而不是任由焦虑说服你一切都不会改变，你所有的恐惧都会成真。它们不会成真的。
I promise this is just a survival instinct. This is just a stress response. Your brain is doing its best to prepare you, but its best is also very imaginative and out there. You know, you've got a really creative mind. That's what, you know, I've had a friend say to me once, she was like, yeah, you're just very creative. And so take that creativity. You can either use it to make it. up, cook up like the most crazy hypotheticals, or you can use it to create something beautiful
我向你保证，这只是一种生存本能。这只是一种应激反应。你的大脑在竭尽全力为你做准备，但它的全力以赴也往往伴随着极其丰富的想象力和天马行空。你知道的，你有着非常具有创造力的头脑。这就是，你知道的，我曾有个朋友对我说过，她说，是的，你太有创造力了。所以，利用这种创造力吧。你要么可以用它来胡思乱想，编造出最疯狂的假设，要么你可以用它来创造美好的事物，
that's going to add to your life. So, as a refresh before we wrap up, here are the four ways that you're going to try, maybe, you can try one, you can try two, you're going to use these to make your anxiety work for you. Hopefully you will go away and when you feel panic, worry, stress. You will tell yourself that it's excitement. You will have an ongoing list of the things that you do know to engulf the things that you don't know. You will put a name to your anxiety. You'll visualize your worries. You'll make a character out of it. And finally, when your anxiety tells you to be small, tells you to deconstruct your life, instead, be creative. Build something, make something. Even if it's like terrible, even if it's shit. Even if you don't, think it's particularly pretty. You'll enjoy the process and it will give the energy again somewhere to go when you turn that creative energy that you have away from the scary hypotheticals and into something beautiful and magnificent.
为你的生活增添色彩。所以，在我们结束之前做个复习，这里有四种你可以尝试的方法，你可以尝试一种，也可以尝试两种，你将利用这些方法让焦虑为你所用。希望当你感到恐慌、担忧、压力时，你能离去并告诉自己这是兴奋。你要列一张清单，写下你所知道的事情，以此来淹没你所不知道的事情。你要给你的焦虑起个名字。你要把你的担忧可视化。你要把它塑造成一个角色。最后，当你的焦虑让你觉得自己很渺小，让你去解构生活时，转而发挥创造力吧。去建造些什么，去创造些什么。哪怕它很糟糕，哪怕它是个垃圾。哪怕你觉得它一点也不好看。你也会享受这个过程，当你不把拥有的创造性能量浪费在可怕的假设上，而是把它倾注于美好而壮丽的事物时，它就会再次给能量找到一个去处。
So I really do hope that if you're going through an anxious period, I think that the biggest comfort for me has been knowing that I am not alone and you're definitely not alone either because I can say, hand on my chest, that I am feeling it pretty intensely at the moment. so we're in the same boat, I promise you, and we'll get through it. We definitely will get through it because your body cannot be in this state forever. It just can't. We know that biologically, we know that. Just when we learn about the stress response, that it's not possible.
所以我真的希望，如果你正经历一段焦虑的时期，对我有过最大安慰的事情就是知道我并不孤单，而且你绝对也不孤单，因为我可以拍着胸脯说，我现在正非常强烈地感受到这种焦虑。所以我们都在同一条船上，我向你保证，我们会挺过去的。我们绝对会挺过去的，因为你的身体不可能永远处于这种状态。它就是做不到。从生物学角度来说我们知道这一点，我们对此有所了解。正如我们了解应激反应那样，这是不可能一直持续的。
So please hold on, try some of these tips. I promise it gets better. I promise this is just your imagination working overtime, which is a beautiful thing sometimes, but sometimes less than helpful. and yeah, I hope that you find some peace in your day today. I hope that this episode has brought you some peace. If you did enjoy it, please make sure that you are following along on Spotify or Apple podcasts.
所以请坚持住，尝试一下这些小建议。我向你保证情况会好转的。我向你保证，这只是你的想象力在超负荷运转，虽然有时候这是一件美好的事，但有时却没那么大帮助。好了，希望你今天能找到内心的平静。希望这一集能给你带来一些平静。如果你确实喜欢它，请确保在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上关注我们。
Leave a five-star review, especially if you're listening on Apple actually, because we actually don't have many listeners over there. So any reviews really do help. And of course, I read every single one of them so they don't go unnoticed. And if you have an episode suggestion, if you have a follow-up to this episode, a question, a query, an additional tip that you think people might also benefit from. Please share it with me at that psychology podcast. Until next time, stay safe.
留下五星好评，特别是如果你正在Apple上收听的话，因为我们在那里的听众其实不多。所以任何评价真的都很有帮助。当然，每一条评论我都会亲自阅读，它们绝不会被忽视。如果你有关于节目的建议，或者对这一集的后续想法、问题、疑问，以及你认为大家也能从中受益的额外小贴士。请在“心理学播客”上与我分享。下次见，保重。
Be kind, be gentle to yourself. And we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
善待自己，对温柔以待。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们这个奇怪现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你最终将成为一个更幸福、更充实、更健康的自己。请收听《2%》。也就是iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方的“TWA%”。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s.
84年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会邀请你一同回顾，剖析曾经发生的事情，并试着和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，弄清楚我们是如何挺过那段时光的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。
It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host care games. This space is about black men's experiences,
那是个疯狂的年代。那是个疯狂的年代。我认为对于黑人来说，再没有比这更重要的年份了。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯主持的《艰难学习》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，
having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
进行那些在其他地方根本不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行这些对话。有多少男人穿着盔甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力并不意味着你需要去使用它，请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难学习》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you. you get your podcasts. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《陷入爱河的陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河的陷阱》播客。这是一个i-Heart播客。百分之百真人保证。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。